Film Courage: Who is your character Butter?
Alex Kersting, Actor: Butter is a very overweight
kid.
He’s not really comfortable in his own skin.
He doesn’t really fit in.
He’s the outcast, the misfit.
Nobody even knows what his real name is even
though he’s never moved around him but don’t
even call him by his real name, they call
him “Butter,” a much, much loathed nickname.
Which the movie very well establishes why
it is loathed.
Film Courage: Well we often see people like
that or we’ve been them ourselves in school
for whatever reason.
And sometimes you see that people like this
actually have an amazing talent or that there
is something very special about them.
Is there something special about the Butter?
Alex: Yes, I think his musical talent is really
where it shines.
He is a…I wouldn’t say prodigy but basically
that level of saxophonist but basically Butter
is one of those kids who could walk into Juilliard,
pick up a saxophone, not even have a reed
on it and still make it sound beautiful.
Film Courage: But his classmates don’t see
that in him?
Alex: His classmates only see him as that
kid who has to have a specially made chair,
who has to have a specially made desk, who
sits by himself, who drinks to cans of Coke
and eats these buffet-style lunches that he
packs for himself.
It’s almost ridiculous the food they’ve
had me eat for the shoot but it fits the character.
Film Courage: If there was a teenager right
now that was in Butter shoes whether it was
just a group of kids that doesn’t like the
person (it doesn’t even have to be where
they are totally different) it’s just that
they got pegged as the outcast which I know
happens, what would your advice be to this
person (male or female)?
Alex: You have to know that you are no alone,
whether it’s at your school, your church,
whatever organization you might be a part
of it doesn’t matter.
Someone also feels the same way you do, whether
you don’t feel tall enough or pretty enough,
buff enough or fast enough, you’re not alone,
everyone feels that way.
Everyone wants to be the best in high school.
The fact is, it doesn’t really matter in
high school as soon as you graduate, it gets
so much better.
All the drama you think you’re dealing with
it goes away pretty quick as soon as the caps
are on your head.
But be prepared of the boredom of graduation.
Film Courage: So when you graduated…you
went to high school in Nevada?
Alex: I went to high school in Henderson,
Nevada (Las Vegas basically).
Film Courage: Okay.
Now do you still go to is it UNLV?
Alex: I went there for a little bit and then
I dropped out top pursue acting a little more
seriously.
School had become a bit more of a distraction
for me so this way I had more time for auditions
and make a little more money with side jobs
and focus on training, characters and stories
that other people react to positive or negative,
something to challenge myself.
Film Courage: Did your parents…were they
okay with that (you leaving college)?
Alex: My dad’s attitude was always you should
at least attend at some point but he knows
college isn’t for everybody.
It took him several, several tries and years
to graduate.
My joke is if he went to college the entire
length he went he would be a doctor and he
only got a bachelor’s.
College isn’t for everybody.
Sometimes it works out, sometimes it really
just is that time where you discover yourself
but it costs a lot of money to go to college
and if you don’t have the money (like I
don’t), you’ve got to make a living some
how, some other way.
And college is going to be there forever so
you can always talk an online class pretty
quick and easy., fairly inexpensively too.
So that’s my recommendation.
Do what is going to save you money, do what
it’s going to take to accomplish your goals.
Film Courage: How did you hear about this
character and film?
Alex: Well my agent submitted me through one
of the many, many acting websites Actor’s
Access I think it is who he submitted me through
but there are like three or four but I’m
not entirely sure which?
I drove in from Vegas not having read the
script, not having read the scene, not really
knowing what’s going on.
The casting director Tannis, she’s amazing,
she was absolutely incredible.
She called me down and said this is what’s
going to happen, here’s the little secret
so it helps your character, make sure it improves
your performance.
You’re going to read this scene, we’re
going to do it a couple times, make sure you
get the best take to the director, and we’re
also going to do a short scene of you improvising
a saxophone solo because that is very important
for the movie.
There wasn’t even a saxophone to play.
“Here’s a ladle.
Play it to the most complicated Charlie Parker
saxophone solo ever made.”
“You ready?”
“No?”
“Okay, ready?
Go.”
And then some how several months later I got
the official casting.
Film Courage: So for several months you did
not know?
You went back to college?
Alex: No.
I’ve been out of college for about a year
and a half now.
But came down for the audition, several months
later they’re like “Hey, can you do several
additional scenes?
I know you’re in Vegas, can you just do
a little video and send it to me?”
So I’ve got my acting coach out there in
Vegas Paul X. Campanella who is amazing by
the way if you ever need a demo reel he’ll
hook you up, he’s amazing.
Shot the two additional scenes, send them
the same day and then a few months later “Okay,
the director still likes you, you’re still
in the mix, we want you to come in for a screen
test and we also want the director to meet
you.
You can do Skype or you can do it in person.”
Skype was probably better for everyone’s
schedule, you can do the Skype interview.
You can discuss what Paul wants to do with
the character, how I connect to the character,
where our similarities lie, and then we try
to build the character around some of the
similarities to me, around Butter in the book
and what Paul’s [Paul A. Kaufman, director]
goals for the character were which kind of
did a little trifecta making it something
a little more three dimensional.
Film Courage: Did you read the book [YA genre
written by author Erin Jade Lange]?
Alex: I did.
I’ve actually read it about three times.
It’s a really good book.
I actually have a copy of it on set with me
every day.
Film Courage: So you went back to Vegas and
you’re working these jobs and you’re waiting
by the phone or the computer?
Alex: I’m waiting just going “Anything,
anything?”
August was the screen-test with the director
and I’m like “Okay, I’m feeling pretty
good.
I’m feeling really good.”
September comes around “I’m not feeling
too good.
Nothing is happening.”
I lost a little hope.
I thought “They went with somebody else.
I would have heard by now.”
Then the week after my birthday in October
they were like “Oh, yeah…you got the part.”
So I run out of the bedroom in my underwear
cheering to my parents I DID IT!
I’M BUTTER!
I’M BUTTER!”
That call woke me up because I work graveyard
security.
11 in the morning my agent called “Yeah,
you got the part.”
“Okay….Oh Gosh!”
Film Courage: How was it going to work that
day or that night?
Alex: I was excited.
I was like “Can’t say anything, can’t
say anything, can’t say anything.”
It eventually came out several hours later.
“I don’t need this job.
I got a movie.
I got the lead role in a movie.
I’m feeling pretty good.”